[موسيقى]
كلاوتي
ملعب
يريد يبيع براسنا
وهو اكو عبارات ممكن نسمعها على المندوب
اللي هي ممكن ايضا تدخل بالقاموس انه هذا
يتمندب علينا طبعا هاي فكره بعض الناس
لكن الفكره الحقيقيه
هو شخص ذكي
متجدد
عند اسلوب
رهيب بتحمل مزاجيات العملاء عند اسلوب
بالاقناع
هذا هو المندوب وهاي الصفات الحقيقيه
للمندوب
بدايتي كانت مندوب طبعا بس بعيد عن الصفات
اللي قلناها اول مره لان هي صفات مو
حقيقيه
لكن انا من اشتغلت مندوب عرفت انه الصفات
الثانيه هي الحقيقيه
طبعا شلون اشتغلت مندوب اجاني احد اصدقائي
حاضر ويانا عمر
رشحني انه اشتغل مندوب بذاك الوقت طبعا
كانت فرص العمل كلش يعني
ضعيفه وما موجوده وصعب الواحد يلقى عمل
ويستمر بيه واكيد الكل يعرف تعيينات
والحكومه ماكو
وبالفعل رحت قابلت
وكانت المقابله كلش صعبه ومعقده واقف فوق
راسي شخص اسمه حجي باسم يمتحني يلا اكتب
على السريع
اشتغل مندوب قضي اموري واطلع لكن ورا هاي
المقابله استنتجت انه لا شغل المبيعات
والمندوب به سر ثاني وفعلا
طبيت اشتغلت مندوب ونجحت بالمقابله
وتفاجات
انه
عالم المبيعات او عالم الشركات او عالم
القطاع الخاص بفرص كلش هوايه حلوه يعني
ممكن الواحد يطور مهاراته ممكن الواحد
يكبر ممكن الواحد يوصل الى طموحه
بجهد وبعمل وبتعب الشركات وراه لان اغلب
الشركات بالقطاع الخاص طبعا بكل مكان مو
بس العراق تدرب الموظف بشكل مستمر تطيم
مهارات الاختلاط اللي يصير بين الشركات هو
اللي يخلي الموظف انه يطور وتكبر مهاراته
ويوصل للي يريده طبعا هذا كان اول تحدي
بالنسبه الي انه هالقى شغل واستمر بيه
التحدي الثاني
طبعا قبل ما اطب التحدي الثاني قبل ما اطب
التحدي الثاني من ضمن مميزات العمل كمندوب
او كم مبيعات يعطينا مهارات ويعطينا شغلات
نقدر من خلالها ندير حتى حياتنا الشخصيه
يعني نعالج اعتراضات يعني مثلا تجي اليوم
زوجتك وهاي معاناه كل الشباب والدين لبيت
اهلي طبعا اذا قلت له لا ما اروح هناك قبت
العيطه وصارت مشكله وانت تضوج من اهلي بس
لو جيت
ما حد يقدر يقول لا بس لو جيت لها باسلوب
لطيف وقلت لها يا بنت الحلال اليوم تعبان
ما اقدر اروح شنو رايك نروح باكر هنا طبعا
هي شنو تونست لان صارت صاحبه قرار واكثر
البنات شو يحبون يصيرون اصحاب قرار او
مثلا اليوم جهالي ما يقبلون ينامون
اروح عليهم
الكل ينام اليوم
طبعا عصبي ها ولا واحد عبرني من جهالي
والكل سهرانين
شو اسوي لهم اجت قلت لهم يا شباب شنو
رايكم لو اليوم تنامون الساعه ثمانيه او
ساعه تسعه ويلكم باكر هديه طبعا بالفعل
ثاني يوم ما ناموا بالتسعه وربع ما يخالف
واخذوا الهديه وصاروا اصحاب قرار براسي
واني سويت اللي اريده ونومتهم من وقت لان
كلهم وين نايمين على التلفونات طبعا هو
هذا التحدي اللي كان او هذا العمل اللي هو
علمني اقوم بهاي الامور كلها ودربني وطور
مهاراتي حتى اسلوبي ويا الناس
والتحدي الثاني اللي كان عندي
بذاك الوقت طبعا اشتغلت بظروف صعبه بوضع
امني غير مستقر حرب طائفيه واحد من اللي
كان يطلع يروح لشغله يمكن ما يرجع سالم لو
مقتول لو مخطوف وطبعا هاي الحال مو بس
بالعراق وهواي بلدان اكو تشبهنا بهاي
الظروف تشبهنا حتى بماضيهم بيحاضرهم
تشبهنا بالقتل تشبهنا بالجوع تشبهنا
بتدهور الاقتصاد تشبهنا بالاحتلال
مثال على ذلك سنغافورا
سنغافوره بلد كان
يمليه المستنقعات
ومليء بالبعوض وشعب جاهل وغير متعلم
ومستعمره بريطانيه
او اكثر الناس اللي كانوا موجودين
يعني صنفوهم تقريبا هي افقر دوله بالعالم
او اف من الناس الفقراء اللي تعتمد على
المساعدات الخارجيه ما بيها لا ذهب ما
بيها نفط جزيره مساحتها ما تتجاوز ال700
750 الف سبعة وخمسين كيلو تقريبا
تعرفون اليوم سنغافوره صارت صارت من اقوى
اقتصادات العالم جوازها سنه 2017 هو جواز
الاول بالعالم كل الشعب متعلم
صاروا اليوم
معدل الدخل السنوي للفرد تقريبا ثمانين
الف دولار
واليوم
85% طبعا من كانوا مشردين اغلبهم وما
عندهم بيوت اليوم 85% من الشعب يمتلك بيت
ملك اللي هو حلم اغلب القاعدين
مو بس هاي
تعالوا وياي خلي اشوفكم
خل نشوف يعني تجربه ثانيه
واسمحولي اسالكم مو جاوبوني منو بيكم شايل
تليفون سامسونج
منو عنده سياره نوع هونداي
ابو
طيب طيب منو عنده اليوم ببيته جهاز
كهربائي ثلاجه غساله مجمده او سامسونج او
اي نوع ثاني
تشوفون تعرفون هاي وين صنعت هاي المواد
كلها صنعت بكوريا الجنوبيه
هاي الدوله اللي هي شنو كانت نفايات
كانت شعب امي
35 سنه محتل كان هذا البلد خمسه وتلاتين
سنه محتل صنفت في وقتها افقر دوله بالعالم
وكان بها حرب اهليه استمرت تقريبا ثلاث
سنوات انتجت خمسه مليون قتيل
واحد رفع ايده
مو بس بالعراق بالعالم كله اليوم الصناعات
الكوريه تدخل كل بيت
وشفتوا وضعهم شلون كان سيء يعني وضعنا هسه
احنا اليوم شويه بس تعالوا اشوفكم بعد
نموذج المانيا
سبعه ونص مليون قتيل
ترى رقم يخوف
مدن دمرت بالكامل مصانع صارت ويا القاع
مصانع صارت ويا القاع وكان 25% من البلد
محتل من اربع دول لا دوله ولا دولتين احنا
مرات نقول فلان تدخل فينا تدخل هنانا
اربعه ما شاء الله اليوم صارت من اقوى
اقتصادات العالم
الثالثه عالميا
بالاستيراد والتصدير
والرابعه بالتصنيع والانتاج وصارت ملاذ
للاجئين
اليوم صارت الهجره كنا وردنا نروح
اوروبا المانيا
طبعا هاي التجارب الدول
ليش نروح بعيد تعالوا
قطر اليوم استضافت اهم حدث رياضي بالعالم
اللي هو كاس العالم وهاي لاول مره
بالتاريخ تصير ببلد عربي او بالوطن العربي
خلينا نقول وثاني مره باسيا
قدروا يجيبون كاس العالم يمهم وقدروا
يجيبون كل الجنسيات يمهم حتى يشوفون بلدهم
تراثهم حضارتهم
تخيلوا واتذكروا هاي الحكايه
شوفوا بعد كم سنه ايش راح يصير
بمستقبل قطر وشلون هذا راح ياثر ايجابي
على الدوله هاي
طبعا بكل بساطه
هاي البلدان او هاي التجارب
سوت اربع شغلات بس مو اكثر
حفظوها
بداوا بالتعليم
بلشوا بالزراعه
وانتهوا بالصناعه
دعمه والقطاع الخاص اللي هو اهم قطاع
موجود بكل الدول
اللي ما حد مهتم بيه اللي اني واحد من
عنده اشتغل بالقطاع الخاص
دعمه والقطاع الخاص وطوروا مهارات الناس
واهتموا بالمواهب ودربوا شعبهم هاي
الاربعه شغلات اللي هي تنمي كل بلدان
العالم لو كان افقر واصغر دوله بالعالم
مثل سنغافوره او بلد بتاريخ او بلد
باقتصاد مثل المانيا
طبعا هاي التجارب تعلمنا انه ماكو شي صعب
ولا مستحيل
وشفنا انه اليوم مو بس بلدنا بهاي المشاكل
هواي بلدان طلعت تشبهنا بس فعليا ماكو شي
صعب ولا مستحيل ونقدر والعراق يقدر
بالمناسبه ان ينهض من خلال التعليم من
خلال الزراعه من خلال الصناعه من خلال
تطوير الافراد كل هذا راح يقدر يلم البلد
وللعلم احنا الشغله الاهم من هذا انه احنا
عندنا اساس يعني قبل سنه 2003 العراق كان
يملك 178 الف مصنع
بين حكومي وبين قطاع خاص وكان العراق
يعتمد على 23% من الناتج المحلي
ون وياي الارقام طبعا مو بس هاي الامثله
اكو امثله بعد هوايه على البلدان واحنا
بعدنا بها بالمناسبه ونقدر نكبر من جديد
وخلال اخر سنتين بلشت تدخل بالعراق
الشركات العالميه
وبلشوا ينشؤون مصانع وراح اعطيكم بعض
الامثله عن هاي المصانع اللي بلشت بالعراق
يعني مثلا مصنع انتاج شيبس ليز
هذا المصنع انت حاليا موجود بالعراق ده
يعتمد على 35% من البوتيتا العراقيه ماكو
البطاطا
من البوتيته العراقيه حتى تحفظوها 35 هاي
النسبه البسيطه اليوم وفرت اكثر من 4000
فرصه عمل من عامل الى مهندس الى فني الى
مندوب الى سائق
معامل انتاج الالبان يمكن اغلبكم اذا يشوف
هسه البان السليمانيه كلش تطلع وتشوفوها
معامل انتاج معجون الطماطم
ذول المعامل بلشوا ويعتمدون على
12% من انتاج المحلي للطماطه العراقيه
وخمسه بالمئه من الحليب وتعرفون هاي النسب
ايش قد وفرت فرص عمل اكثر من 3000 فرصه
عمل
وغيرها بعد عندنا معامل هوايه يعني مثلا
اليوم
تعرفون انه ما حد حيصير عندنا قاعد بلا
شغل وما احتاج عمر اليوم يدز علي للشغل
انا اروح بالسيفي مالتي اقدمه واشتغل ليش
اكو فرص هوايه طبعا كل هاي الفرص
لو انعكست على الناتج المحلي وبلشنا
بالتصدير ايش قد راح تكون واردات البلد
سنويا كم مليار دولار راح ندخل للبلد كم
فرصه عمل راح نضيف
تتخيلون وياي شلون راح ينعكس على حياه
المواطن العراقي
طبعا هاي الصوره تاذيني
لان صوره نحكي بيها عن حضاره بلد بحضاره
اكثر من 7000 سنه تتخيلون انه هذا البلد
راح ينتهي
ماذا اسمع
تتخيلون انه هذا البلد راح ينتهي
طبعا لا تعرفون ليش لان هذا البلد
بخيرات ويمتلك الخيرات الخبرات اللي هو
انتم
بلد شبيه
رددوها ورايا بلد ايش فيه بخيارات وش
يمتلك
يمتلكنا
يمتلك الخبرات فهذا البلد ما ممكن راح
ينتهي
طبعا اكو شغله كلش مهمه انه لازم نتعلمها
من تجاربنا
ومن تجارب الدول الاخرى اللي شفتوها واللي
سمعتوا بها طبعا بعدك هوايه قصص حلوه
وانت اليوم اللي قاعد حاليا اللي تشتغل
كاشير او انت اللي تشتغل مندوب او انت
اللي تشتغل موظف بسيط ما مقتنع بشغلك يمكن
تروح الصبح كلش ضايج للشغل
وتحس انه هذا الشغل ميلبي طموحك لا بالعكس
لان هاي بدايه كل نجاح انت لازم تجتهد
لازم تشتغل لازم تطور لازم تنجح
مثل ما انا قدامكم كنت في يوم ما بس مجرد
رايد ادور وظيفه اللي هي مندوب وكنت
نهائيا ما مقتنع بيها لان هاي الشغله كانت
بعيده جدا عن اختصاص الدراسي
اليوم
قدرت انه اطور نفسي واطور مهارتي وقلت
لازم اسوي شيء مهم بعالم المبيعات
والتسويق والتصنيع وفعليا
اللي كان بالبدايه لوتي بس هو مو لوتي هو
ذكي
واللي كان كلاوتي اللي هو مو كلاوتي هو
بالعكس عنده اسلوب اليوم قدر
ان ينتقل من مندوب بسيط الى مدير تجاري
لاكبر شركه عالميه تسويقيه تصنيعيه
بالعراق وبانتاج محلي وتم تكريمي على هذا
الاساس
[تصفيق]
بالنتيجه يا شباب
خلونا
نزرع اكلنا
ما نستورد بعد خيار وطماطه وخلونا نبني
مصانعنا حتى نصنع سياراتنا
والتلفزيوناتنا وتليفوناتنا
ومثل ما غيرنا قدر ترى احنا نقدر
العراق اكبر من نخاف عليها
[تصفيق]
شكرا
[موسيقى]